[Music]
everyone right now discussing the Obama
Newsweek cover have you seen this have
you seen the Obama Newsweek cover yes
this is crazy the new issue of Newsweek
features President Obama on the cover
with the caption the first gay president
apparently the new managing editor of
Newsweek is a third grade bully okay
this isn't even noticed and his on the
issue right that guy's totally gay right
I don't you saw this earlier today
President Obama went on the view you see
that yeah yeah he went on the view
because they're the only group of women
the president trusts his Secret Service
agents to be around
[Music]
[Applause]
that impression we're good we're fine
we're all right we're good both
campaigns trying very hard to appeal to
young people both presidential campaigns
President Obama has said he has jay-z on
his iPod yeah in an effort to keep up
Mitt Romney said he downloaded
Nickelback to his soon we get some
Nickelback fans here seriously oh yeah
you gotta go
[Applause]
now they're making the sign of the devil
at me
wait that's what wait a minute that is
Nikhil yeah
the only guys that go crazy for
Nickelback in an audience are Nickelback
themselves boots at home an Fox News
commentator Geraldo Rivera says he was
manually raped by a TSA agent yeah which
which explains the TSA s new slogan hey
we finally did something right I like
the phrase manually rape is if there's
like an automatic yeah I'm sure they're
oh they did it they did it homemade yeah
yeah old-school it's exciting as of
Friday you'll all be able to buy shares
of Facebook yeah this is perfect for
anyone who's ever logged onto Facebook
looked at pictures of their friend
eating a sandwich and thought now
there's a sound investment they had have
speaking of investments the head of the
banking giant JP Morgan has apologized
for losing over two billion dollars in a
bad trade yeah this morning he said hey
it could have been worse we could have
signed Albert Pujols
this is crazy do you hear but
researchers are developing a stay sober
pill yesterday his sober pill don't boo
yeah it's gonna be for three Angry yeah
no yeah oh god likes Nickelback and
wants to be drunk researchers are
developing a stay super pill that will
prevent you from getting drunk off of
alcohol this is true yeah it's perfect
for the drinker who wants all the
calories of alcohol but none of the fun
what would possibly be the point I don't
know four designated drivers who don't
like O'Doul's
that's a sponsor and easy shot
sorry O'Doul's yeah in New Jersey a
blind man has won his legal battle and
will be allowed to keep his guns
unfortunately he's already in trouble
for holding up a mailbox
we talked about that one backstage and
went the wrong way
a new study we made the wrong choice a
road diverged in a wood a new study
thanks Nickelback guys a new study I no
no no a new study suggests that men's
brains process sexy women in commercials
as objects not as human beings yeah
whatever all I know is that thing with
big boobs told me to buy yogurt
you